[Music]
Freddy thank you for joining spectator
TV this week and on your birthday yeah
it is my birthday do you want to tell
viewers how old you are uh yes I do a
lot uh I'm 44 today now in the magazine
this week you write about Donald Trump's
bid now this still various stages to go
through he's not yet the Republican
candidate but you say that's pretty
nailed on at this point I think so I
mean I think it's quite fun for
journalists uh and pundits and analysts
to say that uh you know Ronda santis is
ground game in Iowa is really good he
could win Iowa next week Nikki Haley
starting to look a bit of a threat in
New Hampshire and New Hampshire which is
the week after Iowa uh is famously this
Open primary where anyone can vote
pretty much anyone can register to vote
um so therefore Independence can could
sway it for Nikki Haley I think there's
there is a little bit of Truth in all
that but really it's grasping at straws
because the boring reality is Donald
Trump is miles ahead and unless the
polls are monumentally wrong uh he's
going to be the nominee um and really
the race is just a coronation
process in which case uh the argument
you make in your piece is a bit that's
far more uncertain is the next stage
which is the legal rules around whether
Donald Trump can stand or not now we
talked previously on this podcast about
lawfare can you just update viewers of
where we are exactly when it comes to
Donald Trump and uh the barriers he has
to get free to be able to stand well
yesterday Donald Trump was in court in
Washington DC uh and he didn't have to
be there but very interestingly he chose
to be there rather than in Iowa
campaigning um and I'll get on to why
why I think that's interesting next but
just as far as his case is concerned
this is just one of his indictments so
this is the January 6th Federal
indictment uh which is that he he didn't
the charge importantly isn't that he
incited an Insurrection it's that he uh
among other things defrauded the United
States or conspired to defraud the
United
States Donald Trump claims that
presidential immunity the fact that he
was president means that he should not
be charged with the with these crimes um
and so his lawyers were making that case
in DC and it sounded very much yesterday
as though the judges quite skeptical
about Trump's lawyers claims of
presidential immunity so it looks as
though he'll be rejected and he will go
ahead to court for on that indictment in
March the reason I think it's
interesting that Trump chose to be there
rather than in Iowa campaigning or
anywhere else um is because it shows
that Trump knows how good the
indictments are for him or he believes
they are good for him and so far he's
he's been right uh every single
indictment produced uh a further rise in
his polling the mug shot uh the famous
mug shot in August of him in in Fulton
County jail house um that is if you look
at sort of the the chart of his polling
from that moment it's just gone up and
up and up and up so Trump has it's it's
a a risk because of the way it plays out
in the National but certainly among
Republicans Trump knows that these
trials mean that the race is over
because everybody's talking about Trump
they don't care about Ronda santis they
don't particularly care about Nikki
Haley and do you think one of the other
thing that's benefited him is clearly
this is a lot of publicity and this
sense that he is being stopped and
people are not having a right to have
their say um but you also have the fact
that because he is prolific because he
was previously president it's almost say
you've had an incumbent in a way that
doesn't usually happen uh you know when
you're picking your a candidate for one
of these yes I mean I think the
incumbency factor is very strong I mean
the the Republican machine is his to a
certain extent a republican politician
and local activists and so on if they
want to get on in the party if they want
to succeed if they're ambitious uh they
probably have to be very careful not to
say anything bad about Donald Trump
publicly so he has kind of strangled
over over the Republican party and he
has for a long time uh that makes him
very different to your usual candidate
it makes him very different to the
candidate he was in
2016 um he's he's he's hard to beat if
not impossible to beat as far as the
Republican side is concerned now there
are different indictments as you
mentioned
different legal challenges for Donald
Trump uh you know some states where he's
not even being put on the ballot at the
moment what do you think are the most
serious in terms of stopping his root to
getting
there uh I mean I think the most s
dramatic in terms of you know the on the
not just the legal side but the public
side will be the January 6th ST which is
why Joe Biden's been talking about it
this uh week Joe Biden went to Valley
Forge in Pennsylvania and did a big
speech to Mark uh the third anniversary
of January the 6th um I think that one
is the big one I think uh if he goes
down for that but the the point is you
know the way Democrats talk about him
they talk about him like he's Al Capone
so it doesn't really matter which one
they get him on whether it's you know
some complicated tax thing that just
gets him put in jail or thrown away or
just convicted or found guilty in
court uh they talk about him as though
he's such a monster that it doesn't
matter what they get him they just got
to get him and what about the idea that
he could run from a jail cell and then
pardon himself well he could do it and
you know Eugene Debs has run ran for
president socialist uh ran for president
before and got about a million votes
which was pretty surprising for a
socialist in America um there is
obviously if he's in jail it's just very
impossible to imagine what uh that will
be like what whether he will continue to
run I imagine he probably would uh
whether Americans will still uh find the
willingness to vote for him I think
probably not is the answer but then you
do have to remember that Americans have
a very different understanding of the
legal system the British people do I
think when we talk when Brits talk to
Americans about this a bit of a things
get lost in translation um because the
American political system legal system
is very obviously politicized uh and
everybody knows it and so there's a sort
of contempt for it that you don't have
in Britain now one of the interesting
things you wrote about is evangelicals
and the fact that this vote base seems
to be moving towards Donald Trump which
is surprising given they weren't usually
associated with him so what do you think
is there a law of Donald Trump 2.0 when
it comes to this uh well white
evangelicals uh love Trump uh he got 80%
of their support in 2016 I think he got
slightly more in
2020 and what's interesting is that
these are not uh the evangelicals of
their parents' generation they don't go
to church as much uh and yet they
identify with Trump in an almost
religious way I think there's been a lot
of rubbish spoken about this but there's
some very interesting research by Pew
which shows that people identify as
Evangelical now because they support
Trump uh which means that he's actually
a sort of Baptist figure in some ways
for the American right um and that
politics has become the master identity
as some Professor told the New York
Times this week in that people identify
politically as somebody who support
Trump and then they decided they're an
Evangelical and that's a major shift in
America and Trump has really been able
to capitalize on that and I think people
underestimate uh the extent to which his
the sense of him as a sort of spiritual
Warrior is actually quite alive and real
for a lot of Americans I mean you just
have to look online and obviously you
know there's always crazy stuff online
but it's it's a significant thing that a
lot of people think of trump as some
sort of divinely ordained figure uh who
has come to restore America to Greatness
um that sounds crazy to us I know uh but
a lot of people believe it and even if
you don't believe it as a as I trying to
say in the piece the Church of trump is
quite broad you don't really have to
believe that he's divinely appointed but
you can say actually look at the
Democrats what are they doing with the G
with the legal system why are they
persecuting him like this to start
thinking that you know maybe there's
something very unique about him uh and
that I think explains his appeal um now
we talked about things that were're
uncertain on so of course how how this
lawfare works what will happen in the
courts um the other question is who will
his running partner be um now we're
starting to see uh several I think
female politicians thanks to comments uh
Donald Trump and those close to have
made suggesting he might go for a female
running partner this time around trying
to almost position themselves who are
the runners and writers well I I like
that Donald Trump said he likes the
concept of a woman uh being his vice
president and we've read we've read a
lot into that uh so yes there are are
various women are seem to be competing
uh Carrie lake is putting herself front
and center she's doing a lot of uh
greasing up to Trump World I think she's
going to do a big speech next week uh
she is a uh a television presenter
turned uh governor candidate who has
actually failed but like Donald Trump um
complained about the
result uh and then there is um of course
uh Nikki Haley who everybody thinks
Trump might do what he did in 2016 which
he surprised people by picking a sort of
establishment choice and people think
that he might do that with Nikki Haley
they actually have quite a good
relationship Nikki Haley and Donald
Trump uh and that's possible although
Trump World is far more radical now and
Donald Trump Jr promised uh crowds of
his adoring uh Trump fans that he will
not let his father appoint Nikki Haley
um and so that leaves Elise stepanick
who uh is also mentioned in Amber's
piece uh and there are other people like
some people think he might choose tuls
gabbard who a sort of Maverick Democrat
who now presents occasionally on Fox
News um so there are various women
Runners and Riders uh I think the thing
with Trump is he likes to keep everybody
guessing and he sees it as this is the
closest uh that it gets to uh reality TV
that it gets to The Apprentice the show
that he really loved doing um possibly
more than anything else so he loves that
element of I'm you know he's The
Bachelor and he gets to choose who he
who he wants to dance with
and just finally if we do see Trump
obviously be selected get to a point
where he is not in a Cell he is out
their campaigning what do you think the
current I suppose perception of your
average voter in America of Donald Trump
is not the you know hardore Republicans
that get to pick the candidates um you
how is all this looking to them well I
think the thing to remember about
Americans and Trump is that so many
people love Donald Trump intensely so
many people hate Donald Trump intensely
there is a large number of Americans who
don't feel very strongly about Donald
Trump and I think it's those people who
will decide the election um they
probably don't like him very much as a
person but then they're going to look at
the economy and think you know was it
better then than it is now and they may
well say yes so obviously in such a huge
country you have enormously differing
views of Donald Trump I think the thing
to remember is that if you speak to most
Americans uh they won't be as passionate
about Donald Trump as probably the
people you see in the media thank you
Freddy and happy birthday thank you
Katie that was my best birthday present
I could have ever asked
[Music]
for